Catedrática Tamar Gendler:
Necesitamos hacer 2 cosas
en la clase de hoy:
Primero, terminar nuestra
acelerada discusión
sobre deontología.
Estamos intentando ver a Kant en
una clase más o menos.
Quiero terminar con ese tema.
Después, podrán usar sus clickers
y opinar
cuando veamos el problema del
tranvía de Judy Thomson.
Recordarán que en la clase pasada
nuestro objetivo era entender
la selección muy breve
que leímos del libro
Fundamentación para una
metafísica
de las costumbres de Kant, es decir,
las 3 afirmaciones expuestas
en el primer capítulo del
primer libro de ese volumen.
Esas afirmaciones, a las que ahora
he agregado un subrayado,
son las siguientes:
La primera afirmación dice que para que
una acción tenga valor moral,
es necesario que se haga por deber.
Kant realiza la distinción
entre hacer algo por cumplir
con el deber, es decir,
algo conforme a lo que la
moralidad les exige,
y hacer algo no solo por cumplir
sino también por deber.
Según Kant, el valor
moral de una acción
no se determina solo porque
cumpla con el deber.
Esa es una condición
necesaria, pero no suficiente.
Lo que determina el valor
moral de una acción
es que se haga por cumplir con el deber,
por el hecho de cumplir con el deber,
es decir, por el deber mismo.
Lo segundo que Kant intenta defender,
en su libro de Fundamentación,
es la afirmación de que una
acción hecha por deber,
lo que decíamos en la
primera afirmación,
tiene su valor moral
no en el propósito que busca alcanzar,
no en lo que los griegos llamarían
telos, su meta, su objetivo,
sino en la máxima según la cual
se determina dicha acción.
Lo que determina la moralidad de una
acción en el panorama kantiano
es la descripción bajo la cual
se realiza la acción.
Algunos de ustedes vinieron
ayer a mi oficina
y tuvimos un buen debate
sobre cómo determinamos
qué cosas son
consideradas como
máximas.
Animo a quienes estén
interesados en este tema
a que tomen un curso de ética,
donde podrán trabajar los
escritos de Kant
con más a detalle.
Para el propósito de esta clase,
solo necesitamos entender
la sencilla idea
de que a Kant le interesa la
descripción bajo la cual
se realizan los actos y dicha
descripción tiene que satisfacer
una prueba determinada que
veremos en un momento.
Esa es la segunda afirmación de Kant.
La tercera afirmación de Kant
es que el deber es la noción
central de la deontología.
Deon-deber,
el deber es "la necesidad de una
acción por respeto a la ley".
No solo necesitan actuar con el objetivo
de conformarse a la ley,
no solo necesitan articular sus acciones
para que caigan bajo esa norma,
sino que deben asumir que esa ley
es vinculante moralmente para ustedes,
porque reconocen que eso es lo que
la racionalidad les exige.
La ley moral resulta ser la ley que
ustedes mismos se establecen,
como seres racionales, para
gobernar su comportamiento.
Es el único aspecto de su
comportamiento, en el panorama
kantiano,
que no está determinado
por las fuerzas contingentes del
mundo a su alrededor.
Está determinado por el
reconocimiento de su papel
como seres capaces de
vincularse a sí mismos
a una ley establecida por
ustedes mismos.
La razón por la que nos interesaba
abordar estos 3 principios
era para llegar a la famosa formulación
del imperativo categórico de Kant.
Concluimos la clase pasada conociendo
a un miembro de la familia
del imperativo categórico en
respuesta a la pregunta de Kant:
"¿Qué tipo de ley puede
determinar la voluntad
sin hacer referencia a ninguna
intención de esperar un efecto,
para que la voluntad sea considerada
completamente buena sin restricción?".
Kant se impone a sí mismo
esta tensa pregunta
y la responde con el primer
miembro de la familia
del imperativo categórico.
Es "la conformidad universal de
las acciones de la voluntad
con la ley como tal",
solo así, podemos actuar de forma
autónoma y no heterónoma.
¿Qué significa actuar de forma
autónoma y no heterónoma?
Veamos las palabras:
autónoma y heterónoma.
Noten que ambas tienen el sufijo
nomos que significa ley.
Y distinguen la ley a la
cual están sujetos,
en un caso es autónoma y en
otro caso, es heterónoma.
Autónoma.
¿Qué puede significar?
Pensemos en otras palabras
con el prefijo auto-.
Como automóvil.
¿Qué es un automóvil? Un automóvil
es algo con propulsión propia.
Algo que se impulsa con
su propia fuerza.
Actuar de forma autónoma, en
la visión kantiana,
es actuar con base en una ley que
ustedes mismos se han impuesto.
Son autónomos, sujetos a una ley
que viene desde su interior.
Por el contrario, ¿qué
significa ser heterónomo?
¿Qué significa ser heterosexual?
Ser heterosexual significa sentir
atracción sexual hacia individuos
que tienen distinto género que ustedes.
Entonces, ¿qué significa
ser heterónomo?
Es tener una ley sobre ustedes que
viene desde el exterior,
que viene de algo distinto a ustedes.
La idea de Kant es que la
autonomía, la autolegislación,
es posible solo cuando la ley a la
cual conforman su comportamiento
no viene de las contingencias del
mundo, sino desde su interior.
De esta forma, Kant se interesa
en el mismo tipo de cuestiones
que Epicteto y Boecio.
Ambos están muy interesados
en cómo es posible la libertad humana
y Kant dice que la libertad
humana es posible
cuando ustedes gobiernan sus acciones
con base en aquello que
han decidido ser,
con base en las normas a las que
han decidido conformarse.
En particular,
cuando conforman sus acciones con
el imperativo categórico,
que dice, en la formulación que vimos
al inicio de esta sección,
que "obren solo según aquella máxima
que quieran que se convierta
en una ley universal".
Cuando actúan
sin tomar en cuenta las
contingencias de su situación,
cuando se consideran uno más
entre un grupo de seres
que en su situación harían
exactamente lo mismo que ustedes,
solo en ese caso serán libres de las
contingencias de la circunstancia.
La idea es que de cierta manera,
al colocarse más allá de los límites
de los rasgos contingentes
de su experiencia,
más allá de sus límites personales,
consiguen liberarse de las
contingencias del mundo que los
rodea.
Kant sugiere que si
observan este panorama,
verán que se conforma con las
reglas de la racionalidad.
Kant propone que se
imaginen que se enfrentan
a un caso muy particular de una
acción que quieren realizar
bajo una máxima particular.
La máxima que se han
impuesto ustedes mismos es:
"cuando haga una promesa
que me cueste mucho trabajo cumplir,
romperé esa promesa".
La máxima es: "está bien que yo
haga promesas falsas".
Kant dice que supongamos que hacen,
bajo esa descripción,
una promesa que no tienen la
intención de cumplir.
¿Esta máxima puede volverse universal?
Supongamos que sí.
Supongamos que todos, al
realizar promesas,
solo las hiciéramos
pensando en cumplirlas
si nos conviene
y no cumplirlas si no nos conviene.
Si eso pasara, dice Kant,
no existiría tal cosa como
una promesa confiable.
¿Por qué? Porque las promesas
son como los balcones.
No nos paramos en un balcón si
existe una alta probabilidad
de que el balcón se rompa
cuando nos paremos en él.
No confiamos en promesas
o compromisos que los otros nos hagan
a menos que estemos casi seguros
de que cumplirán sus promesas.
Kant dice que la práctica de hacer
promesas se vendría abajo
si todos hicieran promesas
falsas a su conveniencia.
Al hacer una promesa falsa
no cumplimos con lo que la
ley moral nos demanda.
Y sugiere este marco
que puede extenderse a todos los
tipos de deberes que existen.
Kant sugiere que hay dos
categorías de obligación
que tenemos hacia nosotros
mismos y hacia los otros.
Tenemos deberes con nosotros mismos
y deberes con los demás.
Además, dice Kant, tenemos
deberes perfectos,
cosas que siempre tenemos que hacer,
y deberes imperfectos, cosas que a
veces tenemos que hacer.
En los cuatro casos, dice Kant
en el texto que leímos,
podemos ver que el imperativo
categórico nos guía
para saber si una acción está
permitida bajo una máxima.
La acción bajo una máxima
estará permitida
si puede volverse universal y estará
prohibida en caso contrario.
Si nos preguntamos:
"¿Es correcto hacer promesas falsas?".
Y suponemos que
"todos hacen promesas falsas",
entonces, descubrimos que la
acción de hacer promesas falsas
está prohibida por el
imperativo categórico,
porque no puede ser universal.
Supongamos que nos preguntamos:
"¿Es correcto suicidarnos si estamos
frustrados con el mundo?".
Kant dice que supongamos que
todos hicieran eso.
La práctica, el argumento
enrevesado se rompería,
porque ya no quedaría
nadie para suicidarse.
Eso dice el argumento.
Supongamos que nos preguntamos
si tenemos el deber de
cultivar nuestros talentos.
Kant dice que supongamos que nadie
cultivara sus talentos.
Viviríamos en un mundo
en el que nadie querría vivir.
Por lo tanto, tenemos la obligación
moral de cultivar nuestros talentos.
Por último, pregunta:
"¿Tenemos la obligación de dar
dinero a los necesitados?".
Y vuelve a preguntar:
"¿Qué pasaría si hubiera
una ley universal
para que nadie diera dinero a
los necesitados?".
Otra vez, vemos que el mundo ordenado
en el que nos gustaría
vivir se viene abajo.
Es posible cuestionar las
cuatro derivaciones,
aunque por lo general se
acepta que la derivación
de la promesa falsa
es la más efectiva de ellas.
Pero veamos qué dice Kant al respecto,
si resultara que estas
derivaciones funcionaran.
Kant dice:
"estos son algunos de los
deberes actuales
cuya derivación del principio
antes mencionado está clara".
Decir que está claro es
un poco forzado,
pero podemos ver cómo
funcionaría esa derivación.
¿Qué nos dice esto de la moralidad?
Según Kant, esto nos dice que
cuando analizamos un acto
para determinar si es moral,
necesitamos verificar
si estamos haciendo una
excepción para nosotros mismos.
Cuando actuamos, necesitamos querer
que una máxima de nuestras acciones
se vuelva una ley universal.
Kant dice que cuando transgredimos
no queremos que nuestra máxima se
convierta en una ley universal,
sino que queremos que la máxima opuesta
siga siendo una ley universal.
Supongamos que les gusta sentarse
en las últimas dos filas
de este salón,
aunque no lleguen tarde a la clase.
¿Les gustaría que esto
fuera una ley universal?
¿O es algo que solo
funciona para ustedes
si otros están dispuestos a
sentarse más cerca
para que haya espacio para
otros en las escaleras?
Kant diría que la ley moral les
exige que vayan más adelante,
porque sentarse en las últimas 2 filas,
aunque no lleguen tarde,
depende de que otras personas
hagan algo distinto.
Robar depende de que otras personas
respeten las leyes de la propiedad.
Que ustedes no paguen su
boleto del metro
depende de que otras personas sí paguen
para que haya suficiente dinero
para mantener el metro.
Kant dice que cuando hacen una
excepción para ustedes mismos,
están violando la ley moral.
Retomaremos esto
al inicio de nuestro debate de
filosofía política,
cuando hablemos del dilema
del prisionero.
Mencioné de pasada que ya
habían conocido a un miembro
de la familia del
imperativo categórico,
que habían conocido lo que
a veces se denomina
la fórmula de la ley universal:
"obren solo según aquella máxima
que quieran que se convierta
en una ley universal".
Kant otorga 4 distintas opciones
al imperativo categórico
por diversas razones.
Una es que, en ciertos casos,
es más fácil ver cómo aplicar
el imperativo categórico
si lo enmarcamos un poco distinto.
Quiero presentarles las otras 3,
principalmente porque la segunda va
a jugar un papel central
en la segunda mitad de la clase de hoy.
Kant afirma que
"actuar solo de acuerdo
con la máxima que desean que se
vuelva una ley universal"
es equivalente a decir que
"deben actuar de tal forma que
traten a la humanidad,
ya sea en su propia persona o
en cualquier otra,
siempre como un fin y nunca
como un simple medio".
No se usen a ustedes mismos
como medios para un fin
y no usen a los otros en sus
interacciones con ellos
como simples medios.
Traten a la humanidad y a los otros
como fines en sí mismos.
Kant dice que esto es equivalente a
la fórmula de la autonomía,
que ya vimos brevemente.
"Actúen de tal forma que
mediante sus máximas
puedan ser legisladores de las
leyes universales".
Actúen de tal forma que
sean autolegisladores
con respecto a las reglas que
la razón aprueba.
Por último, una idea un
poco complicada,
a veces llamada el reino
de los fines dice:
"actúen según las
máximas de un miembro
que otorga leyes universales para un
posible reino de los fines",
una sociedad en armonía en
la que todos existen
según las leyes que ustedes dan.
Como ya había dicho, solo podemos
dedicar una hora a Kant,
así que no veremos la tercera
ni la cuarta opción.
Pero sí quiero que pongan atención a
la fórmula de la humanidad,
porque como dije, va a
jugar un papel central
en el diagnóstico final de Judy Thomson
sobre cómo podrían explicarse
nuestras intuiciones
en los casos del tranvía.
Permítanme concluir el debate de Kant
intentando conectarlo con la mini
unidad a la que pertenece.
Recordarán que iniciamos esta
sección del curso el día 17,
es decir, el pasado jueves,
considerando el consecuencialismo
como una teoría moral.
Y quiero preguntar:
¿Qué tienen en común las
2 teorías morales
que vimos al inicio de esta unidad?
Hasta el momento hemos visto
algunas diferencias
entre el consecuencialismo
y la deontología.
Pero pienso que es importante,
ahora que pasamos a algunas
aplicaciones prácticas,
pensar en qué tienen en común.
Ambas desde la teleología,
el consecuencialismo-utilitarismo, en la
forma particular que las vimos,
y la deontología prohíben el
excepcionalismo de la primera persona.
Kant dice que nuestros deseos
pueden servir de base
para acciones deseadas solo
si, al mismo tiempo,
congruentemente queremos que otros
en circunstancias similares
actúen igual.
Solo tenemos permitido hacer
cosas que deseemos
que otras personas también
tengan permitido.
Mill cita a Bentham, el bisabuelo
del utilitarismo, diciendo:
"cada persona vale por uno,
nadie vale más que uno".
Mill, en su principio de la
mayor felicidad,
habla de la felicidad para todos,
no de la felicidad desde la
perspectiva subjetiva.
El reto de la moralidad es ver el
mundo no desde la postura
de que sus propias necesidades
son las más importantes,
sino que solo son una
serie de necesidades
entre las necesidades de otros 6
mil millones de seres
igualmente sensibles.
El problema para la moralidad
es que la tendencia al
excepcionalismo de la primera
persona,
a considerar las propias
necesidades como más importantes
que las de los demás es, tal vez,
el sesgo psicológico más
extendido y dominante.
En la unidad de filosofía política,
después de las vacaciones de marzo,
veremos cómo se establecen
estructuras sociales
que nos ayudan a enfrentarnos
a estas tensiones.
Incluso en los pasajes que leímos de
Mill para el jueves pasado,
él habla del tipo de actitudes que es
importante cultivar en los individuos
para que comiencen a ver el mundo
desde una perspectiva moral.
En los fragmentos que leímos del
Libro X de Ética a Nicómaco,
Aristóteles preguntaba:
¿Cómo debe estructurarse una sociedad
para que la gente actúe con
moralidad fácilmente?
La pregunta con la que
cerraremos el curso
-¿Cómo funciona la persuasión
racional contra la no racional?
¿Cuáles son los papeles de las
representaciones literarias
contra las argumentativas
de una buena vida?-
es una versión
operacionalizada de este
dilema.
Dado que los humanos tendemos a pensar
que nuestras necesidades son más
importantes que las de los otros,
¿cómo podemos estructurar la sociedad
para que las necesidades de
todos sean iguales?
Esto es lo que quiero decir de Kant.
En el resto de la clase,
quiero que saquen sus clickers
y disfruten del paseo.
El texto que leímos para hoy
es un excelente y complicado documento de
la filósofa Judith Jarvis Thomson
escrito a mediados de 1980 en
respuesta a un documento previo
de Philippa Foot, otra filósofa
de mediados del siglo.
Philippa Foot y Judy Thomson
están interesadas
en explorar sistemáticamente una serie
de casos que parecen evocar,
en la mayoría de sujetos,
intuiciones bastante poderosas
acerca de qué es lo correcto,
pero que parecen aducir intuiciones
cuya explicación es
difícil de sistematizar.
Como bien saben, el primer caso,
es el del conductor del tranvía.
Aquí tenemos al conductor.
Hay un tranvía que va a toda velocidad
y va a matar a 5 personas.
Pero resulta que se puede
desviar a otra vía
donde solo hay una persona.
Y la pregunta es: El conductor del
tranvía va conduciendo.
Se dirige hacia 5 personas de tal
forma que va a matarlas.
¿Está moralmente obligado, o
tiene moralmente prohibido,
o no tiene prohibido ni está
obligado sino solo tiene permitido,
desviar el tranvía a la vía
donde solo hay una persona?
Aunque esto es un problema en
un marco idealizado,
la desviación de amenazas es algo
a lo que se enfrentan todo el tiempo
quienes toman decisiones.
Supongamos que hay un avión
que dejó de funcionar
y va a aterrizar en una gran ciudad,
pero sería posible desviarlo
para que aterrice en una
zona menos poblada.
Supongamos que una enfermedad
está matando a mucha gente,
pero si pusiéramos en
cuarentena a todos los enfermos,
aunque una gran parte de ellos muriera,
el resto de la población se salvaría.
Caso tras caso, nos
enfrentamos a dilemas
con una estructura similar al
problema del tranvía.
Aunque estos casos están idealizados,
en el sentido que sabemos con seguridad
cuáles serán los resultados,
pienso que son útiles.
Aunque nos interese la
moralidad en el mundo real,
es útil pensar en qué es lo
correcto a través de estos casos.
Comencemos con el caso del
conductor del tranvía.
El tranvía va a toda
velocidad por la vía.
Si el conductor no cambia de
dirección, matará a 5 personas.
Tiene la opción de desviar el
tranvía a una vía
donde solo hay una persona.
Pregunta: ¿Es moralmente obligatorio
que desvíe el tranvía hacia
una persona en vez de 5?
¿O está moralmente permitido,
pero no es moralmente
obligatorio desviar el tranvía?
¿O está moralmente prohibido
desviar el tranvía hacia una
persona en vez de 5?
Ok. Veamos los resultados.
Voy a anotar esto, porque lo vamos
a necesitar más tarde.
El 7%, muy pocos,
piensan que está moralmente
prohibido desviar el tranvía.
La gran mayoría, casi 2/3, piensa que
está moralmente permitido,
pero que no es moralmente
obligatorio desviar el tranvía.
Alrededor del 30%, más o menos 1/3,
piensa que es moralmente
obligatorio desviar el tranvía.
Caso número 2: Trasplante.
Ustedes dirigen un hospital.
Aparecen 5 personas en su hospital,
todas destinadas a morir,
porque cada una necesita un
órgano distinto:
pulmón, corazón, riñón,
hígado y cerebro.
Todas van a morir y ustedes
son los doctores.
De pronto, en la sala de urgencias
entra un joven completamente sano
que tiene un corazón,
un pulmón, un riñón, un
hígado y un buen cerebro.
Si pudieran descuartizar a ese joven
y donar sus órganos a los otros
5 individuos que sufren,
podrían salvar a los 5 a cambio de uno.
Pregunta: Para el médico: A)
¿Es moralmente obligatorio
descuartizar al hombre sano para
salvar a los otros 5?;
B) ¿Está moralmente permitido,
pero no es moralmente obligatorio?;
o C) ¿Está moralmente prohibido?
Veamos los resultados. Entonces.
El 85% piensa que está
moralmente prohibido
descuartizar a 1 para salvar a 5.
El 9% piensa que está
moralmente permitido,
pero no es moralmente obligatorio.
El 6%, que debe ir directo a la
escuela de medicina,
piensa que es moralmente obligatorio
descuartizar al hombre sano.
¿Qué está pasando?
Philippa Foot, la persona que presentó
esta yuxtaposición inicialmente,
tenía una hipótesis.
Su hipótesis era:
En el caso del conductor del tranvía,
el conductor tiene que decidir
entre matar a 1 o a 5.
Mientras que en el caso del trasplante,
el doctor tiene que decidir entre
matar a 1 o dejar que 5 mueran.
Si tuviéramos que medir esto en lo
que yo llamo el malómetro,
que indica qué tan malas son las cosas,
descubriríamos que dejar
que mueran 5 es malo,
pero matar a 1 es peor y matar
a 5 es todavía peor.
Esto parece indicar
que si matar a 5 es peor que matar a 1,
en el caso del tranvía está bien que el
conductor desvíe el tranvía,
pero como matar a 1 es peor
que dejar que mueran 5,
en el caso del doctor, no está
bien descuartizar al hombre.
Porque en el caso del doctor, tiene
que matar a 1 para salvar a 5,
mientras que en el caso del tranvía,
el conductor tiene que matar a
1 para no matar a 5.
Parece coincidir bastante
con sus intuiciones.
El 93% piensa que en el caso del
tranvía está permitido desviarlo,
mientras que solo el 14% piensa
que está permitido,
en el caso del doctor,
matar a una persona.
Parece que el malómetro
captura bastante bien
las intuiciones de este salón.
De hecho, los estudios
empíricos realizados
en miles de personas de todo el mundo
sugieren que sus intuiciones
están bastante alineadas
con las intuiciones de la mayoría.
Pero hay un problema.
Caso número 3: el
transeúnte del tranvía.
Aquí está Jim.
Pobre Jim.
Tiene muy mala suerte.
Primero está en una aldea
latinoamericana
donde tiene que disparar a
algunas personas.
Ahora está aquí cerca de un
tranvía que va a toda velocidad
y matará a 5 personas.
Pero aquí, en medio de la vía, hay un
interruptor que si Jim lo gira
hará que el tranvía mate
a 1 en vez de 5.
Pregunta: Para Jim, el transeúnte,
¿es moralmente obligatorio
desviar el tranvía
para que choque contra 1 en vez de 5?
¿Está moralmente permitido,
pero no es moralmente obligatorio
que desvíe el tranvía?
Esa es la respuesta 2.
¿O está moralmente prohibido
que desvíe el tranvía?
Veamos los resultados.
Ok. Aquí están los resultados.
15, 70 y 15.
Estos resultados son muy similares
a los del caso del
conductor del tranvía.
En el caso del conductor,
el 63% pensaba que estaba
moralmente permitido,
mientras que aquí el 70% piensa que
está moralmente permitido.
En el caso del conductor,
el 30% pensaba que era
moralmente obligatorio.
Aquí, menos piensan que es
moralmente obligatorio: 15%.
En el caso del conductor, el 7%
pensaba que estaba prohibido.
Aquí, el 15% piensa que está
moralmente prohibido.
Ha cambiado un poco, pero no mucho.
Aquí está el problema.
Recuerden que en el
análisis del caso de Foot,
sabíamos que dejar morir a
5 era un poco malo,
que matar a 1 era peor y que
matar a 5 era incluso peor.
El conductor del tranvía tenía que
decidir entre matar a 1 o a 5.
En el trasplante, tenían que
decidir entre matar a 1
o dejar que 5 murieran.
¿Pero, qué pasa en el
caso del transeúnte?
En el caso del transeúnte, Jim,
el de la mala suerte,
tiene que decidir entre matar a uno,
desviando el tranvía hacia otra vía,
o dejar que mueran 5,
dejando que el tranvía choque
contra esos 5 inevitablemente.
A diferencia del caso del doctor,
donde el 85% pensaba que
estaba prohibido matar a 1
para salvar a 5, que de lo
contrario morirán,
en este caso, el 85% piensa que por
lo menos está permitido
matar a 1 y no dejar que 5 mueran.
Voy a repetirlo.
Observen el malómetro, el 85%
piensa que pasa al revés.
¿Qué está pasando?
Pensábamos que teníamos una
solución al problema.
La solución al problema del
trasplante o del conductor
radicaba en la diferencia entre
matar y dejar morir.
De repente, muchos piensan que es peor
que el transeúnte deje morir
a 5 a que mate a 1.
Deben pensar así o no pensarían
que al menos está moralmente
permitido que desvíe el tranvía.
Las cosas se ponen todavía peor.
Supongamos que el caso del
hospital pasa así:
Aparecen 5 personas sanas en el
hospital y el doctor,
que está cansado o que
quiere sacar provecho
de los seguros médicos
porque le conviene
que haya muchos pacientes
enfermos en el hospital,
envenena a las 5 personas
y provoca que cada una necesite
un órgano distinto:
un hígado, un riñón, unos
pulmones, un corazón
y un cerebro.
Como resultado de sus acciones
estas 5 personas morirán.
Unas horas más tarde recapacita.
"¡Me había olvidado del
imperativo categórico!
¡Qué tonto! ¿Qué voy a hacer?".
De pronto, se aparece una persona
sana y el médico piensa:
"¡Dios mío! Ya tengo la solución,
lo voy a cortar en trozos:
corazón, pulmón, riñón,
hígado y cerebro.
Podré salvar a los otros 5. Ok.".
Pregunta: Para el doctor que
envenenó a 5 personas antes
y que ahora tiene la
opción de salvarlas
matando a otra persona:
A) ¿Es moralmente obligatorio
descuartizar a la persona sana?;
B) ¿Está moralmente permitido,
pero no es moralmente
obligatorio hacerlo?;
o C) ¿Está moralmente prohibido
descuartizar a la persona sana?
Veamos los resultados.
Bien. Entonces.
82%, 11% y 7%.
Aquí los resultados son casi idénticos
a los del caso original del doctor.
Ahí había 6, 9 y 85;
aquí hay 7, 11 y 82.
Casi no hay diferencia.
Volvamos a nuestro malómetro.
Dejemos a un lado la cuestión
de matar o dejar morir,
y solo veamos la cuestión
de matar a 1 o a 5.
Sabemos, por el caso del conductor que
matar a 1 es bastante malo.
Pero, la mayoría,
el 93%, piensa que matar a 5
es peor que matar a 1.
Ok. El doctor que envenena.
Tiene estas opciones: Puede matar a 5.
Ya las envenenó y ahora van a morir.
O puede solo matar a la persona
sana que acaba de llegar.
En consecuencia, las
otras 5 no morirán.
El 82% dijo que era mejor
matar a 5 que a 1.
Voy a mostrarles esto otra
vez en el malómetro.
El 85% pensaba que era mejor que
matara a 5 en vez de a 1.
Tenemos estos 2 maravillosos principios
que parecen explicar qué es lo que
pasa en el caso del tranvía.
Por un lado, pensábamos que matar a 1
era peor que dejar morir a 5,
de repente, un transeúnte
nos hizo pensar
que tal vez no teníamos esa intuición.
Por otro lado, teníamos la
intuición de que matar a 1
era mejor que matar a 5,
pero el caso del veneno también
nos hizo reconsiderar esto.
Hay una cuestión obvia
que podría marcar la
diferencia moral aquí.
Hay una diferencia temporal
de cuándo sucede la acción de
matar a uno y matar a 5.
Tal vez, dice Thomson,
esto podría explicar nuestra
intuición en el caso del doctor.
Tal vez, matar a 5 se ha
convertido en dejar morir,
debido al paso del tiempo, y
esto resulta engañoso
al intentar describir este caso como
matar a 1 contra matar a 5.
Pero la temporalidad no nos ayuda
al comparar el caso del trasplante
con el del transeúnte.
Esos parecen ser casos muy claros
donde tenemos que elegir entre matar
a 1 y dejar que 5 mueran.
Aunque parecía muy claro
para la mayoría,
en el caso del trasplante,
que matar a 1 era peor que
dejar que 5 murieran,
parece estar muy claro que
para la mayoría,
en el caso del transeúnte,
pasa lo contrario.
El problema del tranvía
es el problema planteado por
estas flechas que se mueven.
¿Cómo sistematizamos nuestras
intuiciones sobre matar
o dejar morir si parece que se
derrumban en estos casos?
Thomson sugiere que aunque el
caso del trasplante
nos da la opción de matar a
1 o dejar morir a 5,
igual que el caso del transeúnte,
existe una diferencia
potencialmente relevante entre
ellos.
La diferencia es que en el
caso del trasplante
usamos a una persona como un medio.
La usamos para lograr el resultado
de salvar a otras 5 personas.
Mientras que en el caso del transeúnte,
al desviar el tranvía a otra vía
donde solo hay una persona,
no usamos a esa persona
como un medio y…
¡Les dije que volveríamos a
Kant y lo logramos!
¿Qué decía la fórmula de
humanidad del Kant?
La fórmula de humanidad de Kant decía:
"Deben actuar de tal forma que
traten a la humanidad,
ya sea en su propia persona o
en cualquier otra,
siempre como un fin
y nunca como un simple medio".
Esa podría ser nuestra solución.
Quizás el problema en el
caso del transeúnte
es que como no ven a la
persona como un medio,
parece correcto matarla.
Mientras que en el trasplante,
ven a la persona como un medio y
no es correcto matarla.
Por lo tanto,
están obligados moralmente a
dejar que las otras 5 mueran.
Thomson dice que esto no
puede estar bien.
Supongamos que ustedes son Jim y están
parados al lado del tranvía.
El tranvía va, igual que siempre,
en dirección a 5 personas a
las que va a matar.
Aquí, en vez de una vía
recta con una persona,
hay una vía en bucle y la
persona está en medio.
Si desvían el tranvía, le
pegará a esta persona
y gracias a eso se
salvarán a las otras 5.
Pregunta: En el caso que
Thomson llama "bucle" es:
A) ¿Moralmente obligatorio
desviar el tranvía?;
B) ¿Moralmente permitido, pero no
moralmente obligatorio?;
o C) ¿Moralmente prohibido?
Recuerden que el tranvía se
dirige hacia 5 personas.
Ustedes son Jim.
El tranvía chocará contra 5 personas
o si lo desvían a la vía de bucle,
donde hay una persona a la que golpeará,
lograrán detener el tranvía.
¿De acuerdo? Veamos los resultados.
Ok. Entonces, 68, 18 y 14.
No hay mucha diferencia.
Han respondido al caso del
transeúnte en el bucle
casi igual que en todos los
casos del tranvía.
Generalmente la distribución
ha sido 15, 70 y 15.
Eso fue el caso del transeúnte.
Aquí tenemos 14, 68 y 18.
Pero noten que en este caso,
estaban usando a la persona en la
vía de bucle como un medio.
La están usando como un medio
para alcanzar su fin.
Están intentando detener el
tranvía usando su cuerpo.
¡Kant no nos ayudó mucho!
Volvamos a evaluarlo.
Thomson decide volver a
evaluar la situación.
Tal vez, parte de la
decisión está influida
por alguna noción de derechos.
Tal vez, en el caso del trasplante,
donde no dejan que el doctor
descuartice al hombre sano,
es porque piensan que se violarían
los derechos de ese hombre.
Tal vez, sea cierto que
"los derechos sean más
importantes que la utilidad".
Es decir, cuando alguien tiene derecho
a la integridad de su cuerpo,
eso está por encima de las
necesidades de los demás.
Por encima del beneficio de las 5
personas que se salvarían.
Concluiremos esta clase con
un último ejemplo
que pondrá a prueba esta hipótesis.
Comenzaremos la siguiente clase
con algunas razones que la gente
suele dar a esta respuesta.
Ahora supongamos que en vez de la
vía en bucle hay un puente.
Supongamos que encima de ese puente
está este caballero gordo.
Ahora se les presenta este dilema:
El tranvía va a toda
velocidad por la vía.
Está a punto de matar a 5 personas.
Jim, el transeúnte, lo podría
evitar de esta manera:
Podría tirar al hombre gordo del
puente y así provocar
que el tranvía se detuviera en la
vía gracias al peso del hombre.
Pregunta: En este caso,
¿es moralmente obligatorio
tirar al hombre gordo?,
¿está moralmente permitido, pero no
es moralmente obligatorio?
o ¿está moralmente
prohibido aventarlo?
Den sus opiniones, y para
concluir esta clase
les daré los resultados y haré una
observación al respecto.
Veamos si hay algún cambio en el
caso del hombre gordo.
¡Dios mío! Salió
completamente diferente.
¿Qué está pasando?
Recuerden que nuestra
distribución clásica
es 70% más o menos aquí y no más de
10% en la opción de prohibido.
De repente, el 78% piensa
que está prohibido.
¿Qué está pasando?
¡Los dejaré en suspenso!
Hablaremos de esto el martes.